it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best that's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollar you
know what imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery so I thank you any
theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny Michael hey there Boyle how
was your weekend well actually I got a
little sick oh really
sorry to hear that man yeah bullets over
Broadway was on TV I came down with a
big old Dianne Wiest infection
like yeah okay here's the situation your
parents went away on a week's vacation
they left the keys to the brand-new
Porsche okay mine well of course not
I'll just take you for a little spin and
maybe show it off to couple of friends
I'll just cruise around the neighborhood
I shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walk and I picked up my car
phone to perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof was open
the music was high and that girl's hand
was steadily moving up my thought she
had opened up three buttons on her shirt
so far I guess that's why I didn't
notice that police car I can't believe
it I made a mistake my parents are the
same no matter time nor place so to all
your kids all across the land no need to
argue parents just don't understand
something I know so what's up someone is
on fire in Rams at park they need you to
get down there right away oh my god yeah
I never thought this day would come
[Music]
congratulations
it's me Kirk CC plasters mascot I was
inside you razzmatazz so do you
recognize any of these men I was hiding
in the bathroom stall so I didn't see
his face but I heard him he was singing
along to the music at the bar do you
remember what he was singing I think he
was that song I want it that way
Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay number
one could you please sing the opening
two I want it that way
really okay you are my fire number two
keep it going the one desire
number three believe when I say number
four I want it that way tell me why
ain't nothin I never wanna hear
Oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
god I forgot about that part so while
they repaint the lines in the parking
lot we're asking everyone to do street
parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn alright moving
on to recycling you okay run just a
little tooth pain I'm fine continue okay
each department will be getting blue
bins do you need to go to the dentist
Ron I don't like dentists just a second
[Applause]
oh I'm sorry everybody what were we
talking about recycling dentist pulled
the tooth out yesterday but it's always
a good idea to demonstrate to your
co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
last week I give a fire safety talk and
nobody paid any attention it's my own
fault for using PowerPoint PowerPoint is
boring people learn in lots of different
ways but experience is the best teacher
today smoking is gonna save lives
I said I wouldn't smell anything smokey
did you bring your jerky in again oh my
god oh my god Oh fire oh my goodness
what's the procedure what do we do
people Oh
how did that happen out in the hall no
we don't know that the smoke could be
coming through an air duct oh my god
okay it's happening everybody stay
conversation everyone what's the
procedure
calm down no no Michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
what does warm mean here's the door
check that one out how's the handle
woman can I wait things can be replaced
Phyllis people human lives however can
this was hot - okay we're trapped
everyone for himself
cover the mouth all right
let's remember those procedures what's
wrong way we've already tried that
[Music]
[Music]
use the surge of fear and adrenaline to
sharpen your decision-making okay I am
NOT dying
[Music]
[Applause]
attention employees of Dunder Mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise so
what have we learned
oh come on it's not real
daily Stanley you will not die
Stanley Stanley maracas Brendan you are
black satellite I wanna give her
mouth-to-mouth her oh don't give them
out the mouth for this swallow this time
open your mouth Michael
you